how are you doing today we're gonna talk
about how to power level in Division two
if you listen to these tips you should
hit level cap by the time you reach the
end of the game if you don't there's a
slight chance that you might get to the
end of the game and have to grind a
bunch to actually get to the level cap
and engage with the end game so here we
go the first thing you should do is go
to the White House quartermaster and
invest as many points as possible into
the XP boosting perk
this perk will give you extra xp for
things like headshots multi kills etc
it's going to result over a long period
of time through the campaign in a lot
more XP to your character next once you
unlock settlements go to the settlement
project area these projects can actually
net you a lot of XP and they often tie
into activities that you're already
doing now first you'll probably think
you have to go to the settlement to
complete these projects but the truth is
you can actually just open up your menu
and donate items from there so
constantly check your settlement
projects they give you a lot of XP when
you're done with them and they also
result in crafting blueprints don't
bother playing main missions much above
your level it doesn't appear that they
give you more XP than completing them at
your same level and they take a lot
longer whenever you level up go to your
inventory and open caches they usually
drop gear around the highest level stuff
in your inventory and make sure you keep
the highest level armor and gear with
you even though it might not be the best
item that you own because the game
supposedly scales your drops off of what
you have and if you deconstruct it or
sell it you might get lower level drops
now these tips will probably get you to
about level 17 fairly easily
at which point you'll need to start
doing some world farming control points
are particularly good for this since
they give you lots of XP they make the
environments generally safer for you and
you get lots of loot from the supply
rooms those events should get you
through the early 20s if you go between
them and main missions now here's what
you should be doing from about mid 20 to
30 hold on to a number of side missions
until you get to about your mid 20s you
can complete some of them if you need
them to get to main missions but keeping
them in reserve can help you in a number
of ways first off they scale to your
level and you could possibly get to your
high 20s and not have enough events to
do to get you over the hump the level
cap so don't complete all of the side
missions hang on to a bunch of them that
you can then complete at your level to
get to 30 now this game can be pretty
brutal if you're doing it solo because
your health doesn't naturally
generate until you're done with an
encounter so if you get in trouble call
for help from other agents or respond to
those calls for help from other agents
this is also a great thing to hold on to
if you're in your high 20s and you've
run out of activities to get to level
cap you're helping other people out
generally the game scales to your level
regardless of who you're helping so you
might be helping a really low level
player out and you also get xp for
missions that you've already done which
might be a little boring to just run
solo now if you call on those agents for
help another thing that you can do is a
hard daily bounty which unlocks at a
certain point from the White House
do not do hard bounties alone because
you have a time limit and they vanish
when you die they're also a little bit
cheap sometimes and can kill you very
quickly so I highly recommend doing them
with other people if you don't have
friends match make into it or wait for
another player to come now these final
two will give you a little bit of extra
XP one of them is go ahead and join a
clan you can just search through the
menus and find one you get XP through
group challenges and the other one is if
you really need it go pick up six weekly
Ubisoft Club challenges you can find
those off the main menu and they'll give
you just a little bit more XP each week
so that should get you to level cap if
you have tips that we haven't covered I
know we didn't talk about the dark zone
or PvP let us know in the comments below
we'd love to hear your thoughts on
getting the level cap quickly and most
importantly you don't have to get to
level cap quickly this is a big game and
if you want to take your time and enjoy
it you totally should alright thanks for
watching